Eight out of ten buildings in Europe
were constructed before 1990.
These buildings are structurally weaker,
consume lots of energy
and are at greater risk of seismic losses
as requirements were lower some decades ago.
National authorities find it hard to develop plans
to renovate buildings on such a scale.
The task requires a huge amount
of information and technical knowledge.
Could we help them choose the best
strengthening technologies
for their specific types of buildings?
Could we support them also by involving
engineers, architects and construction companies?
We provide technical guidelines to help
them do this large-scale planning,
all backed by data and impact
evaluation tools they can directly use.
We started by producing a set
of technical guidelines.
We chose regions in Europe
where renovating would make the biggest impact,
whether because their buildings were older
or because the seismic risk was high,and often both.
We then created a web platform
to attract the interest of national authorities
and disseminate these guidelines.
As information is key,
we share evaluations of the efficiency
of different technologies,
their cost and a measure of their impact
during the entire life cycle.
We have even developed a methodology to assess
the multiple cumulative benefitsof strengthening buildings
This can be used to estimate the economic gains
of lowering energy billsand of reducing seismic losses.
We analyzed 105 million buildings
in the European Union.
We identified the top 20 priority regions
where almost 12 million people live.
Our recommendations can now
directly feed into renovation plans
that could benefit millions of Europeans.
We are a team of European Commission
scientists and experts from across Europe
who work together on the integrated seismic
and energy renovation of buildings